[Music]
spring
in bloomington indiana starts off this
hour hi spring how are you
oh great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
wonderful well i'm on baby step one
i've just had the second class of fpu
and i'm looking ahead at the debt
snowball and now i know you
say to pay off all debt but the mortgage
but i'm looking at the mortgage and it's
right about the same amount
as my student loans and by the time i
get to the student loans
the mortgage is going to be less and i'm
thinking
that i'm actually going to be able to
get out of debt faster if i tackle the
mortgage before the student loans
and um then be able to use that uh
mortgage payment to slam on the student
loans
nope nope your thinking got you where
you are
i'm not no i couldn't
i'm sorry that was too easy it was an
underhand pitch darling
i do need to get uh increase my income
and i'm working on that okay stop stop
stop stop stop how much you get how much
debt
do you have on your student loan it is
um hang on a second here
30 uh just over 39 000 just under 40 000
gotcha and how much other debt do you
have not counting your house
i've got um well i'm catching up on my
estimated taxes for 2020 that's my
number one goal right now
i have a 2019 tax bill of of
3811. um
i have a charged off mastercard that
i've been paying every month
for four years which is fourteen
thousand five hundred sixty dollars
and then i have the student and the
student loans and you said the student
loan was how much again
just under forty thousand okay so all
right so
eighteen uh you have 58 000
in debt not counting your house and what
is your income
um my net business income right now
uh projected is where did that number
come off to
all right let's calculate i calculated
my uh projected net business income for
the year
end of june and that was thirty five
thousand seven hundred eighty six
dollars and fifty six cents
and that's pre-tax okay and so that's
what you make
a year yes okay and you said you're
doing something to get your income up
right
i'm working on that i've got it need to
get a few pieces of equipment so i can
start online tutoring i have an
ms in language education which i'm not
using at the moment
and i know there's a lot of online
tutoring available and i've got lots of
experience
that's great yeah how much do you owe on
the mortgage spring
it is uh just under 45 000 and it's
actually in my late father's name
okay there's a lot of reasons
um in this situation to work the system
exactly the way you've been taught
and um the good news is and i'm proud of
you you're paying attention i'm poking
fun at you a minute ago but you're
paying attention now
you're paying attention you're thinking
and uh
before things were just happening to you
and now you're happening to them
and that's a big sign and chris it
really is and you're thinking but here
here's the
other side of that you want to make sure
that you're following a recipe that's
going to help you cook something you
want
these baby steps young lady are going to
lead you in that direction
so don't overthink it don't add anything
to the recipe this is one you want to
follow
to a t so as you get your income up and
you get on a budget you're going to feel
like you've got a raise from just doing
the budget
the stuff the stuff you're learning i've
been doing the every dollar boy that's
going to help yeah good i'm glad
and so that and then what's going to
happen is you're going to reach over and
pay that 4 000
tax bill the 3 800 tax bill be done with
that
and then you're going to reach over and
get rid of this mastercard's been
hanging over your head for a long time
when you've just done those two things
you're going to feel like a new person
aren't you yes this has been a problem
anyway this has been a subject that has
plagued you for a long time
oh gosh five years ago was dreadful
yeah and for the first time in your life
you're going to see
a hope about this a light at the end of
the tunnel that's not an oncoming train
and by the time you've knocked out those
two things
that student loan is going to be in your
crosshairs and you're never going to
blink
and you need to go ahead and knock it
out because it's consumer debt number
one
number two it's in your name the other
debt is not in your name
right and we need to clear it because
it's not going to go away
the problem with the student loan is
emotionally it looks like such a large
mountain
that i don't think i can move it but you
know what when you move a dump truck low
today
you look up and the whole mountain's
gone poor true
and you're gonna get there and then
you're gonna reach over and the good
news is you don't have much of a
mortgage
and you'll be able to reach over and
knock out baby step six later
without any effort at all because you're
going to be in such a you're going to be
in such a
zone by then again having power over a
subject that has controlled you
and instead you're going to be
controlling it you're going to see a
different
whole different side of yourself you're
going to end up
making more money than you've ever made
and you're going to end up with a sense
of confidence that you've never had when
you finish this i promise you
i've worked with people just exactly
like you the language you're using the
way you're talking about this
the the way i look down i see a bad irs
i see an
old mastercard these tell me it's been
going on a while
and so i'm reading into these clues
about your life that you gave me and i
just see
you're gonna 18 months from now you're
going to be a
completely different person a whole
different spot in spring i'm going to
tell you
that another thing a person like you
needs you are motivated i hear the
energy in your voice
but you still need community i'm going
to encourage you to hop over into ramsey
plus
so you can get connected you're in there
with other like-minded people
you're going to be able to cheer other
people on but at the same time
get your own motivation to help you go
faster so
hop over in there be connected with
people that are speaking the same
language and i'm telling you you won't
regret it
yeah it's a good thing i'm glad you're
in financial peace university and it's
i'm glad it's helping you i'm excited
for you
and so uh chris is right we you know the
recipe this is how you make gumbo this
is how you make a chocolate cake
and if you want a good one you just take
the you know the
the chef who's been in the kitchen
that's right for decades knows how to do
it and you follow that recipe
yep and after you've been cooking it for
years if you want to change it up
right that's fine yeah but right now you
suck at this
so go use the recipe learn it if i'm
gonna make biscuits i suck at making
biscuits i gotta get a recipe out i
gotta follow instructions
yes or i'm not gonna get biscuits i'm
gonna get donuts
and you know it's what happens i'm not
gonna get chocolate cake i'll get a dead
gum coconut cake or something
now my wife has been cooking for years
and is a world-class cook and so she
says i just threw this together and i
just made this up
well you can do that after you've been
doing it a long time that's right but
the first time you do it yeah like
i love that analogy chris follow the
directions
follow the instructions they won't steer
you wrong
that's how it works